hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website com2 they're going to be
only over game nine from the 2013 World
Chess Championships between an on the
current world champion at Magnus Carlsen
the young Norwegian star who is the
highest rated chess player in the world
and currently coming into this game has
a two-point advantage with only four
games left so if he can just kind of
squeak by get some drawls then we're
probably going to have a new champion
good news for the fans we have the most
exciting chess match to show you not
only the most exciting chess match of
this entire series but one of the most
fun chess message to watch and to
analyze that I've seen in a long time so
definitely in store for a good one an on
playing the white pieces has to play for
win and that's exactly what he does he
comes out guns blazing and starts out
with pawn to d4 there's actually a lot
of cheers when he played this he's very
strong with d4 Magnus Carlsen plays
Knight f6 and we come into the
nimzo-indian defense which can be very
very aggressive from both sides of the
fence which is what we saw now anon
decided to play an interesting move
which basically told me from the very
beginning that he was not looking to
play the standard cut-and-dry
nimzo-indian defense he played pawn to
f3 which is not something you typically
see I'm used to seeing pawn to e3 I'm
used to seeing Knight to f3
but pawn here to f3 em and it blocks off
this knight on f3 but it gets ready to
push forward with pawn to e4 the
nimzo-indian defense usually don't
castle on the Queen side so even having
this protection on the Kings side when
you castle is look you know usually
pretty important but this pond f3 says
that you know a nan is looking to push
forward on the King side and he's not
too worried about any defense for as
king decide safety if he even decides to
castle on the King side black responds
with pawn to d5 knowing that the NAM
wants to play this pawn to e4 just
dominating this here in the board so
pawn to d5 definitely a nice move for
Magnus Carlsen he can now get this
LightSquared bishop involved into the
game but this kind of counter attacks
the center of the board before things
get too out of hand now we see pawn to a
three no great square for the bishop to
really go to and so magnus carlsen
decides to go ahead and give double
pawns here on the C file you don't
typically in the nimzo-indian Vince want
to bring your bishop back here to a5
because you're going to lose it after
the pawn comes up and then this pawn
pushes forward pushing back is a little
bit too passive especially since White
has so much spatial advantage this would
definitely kind of be bad for black and
so it's pretty common just to go ahead
and exchange giving up that Bishop your
opponent has that bishop pair but giving
them this double pawn structure right
here on the C foul this also does open
up a send me open file for the rook so
having the rook swing over here to b1 at
some time controlling this long file
kind of opening up that the Queen side
attack is definitely something that
white could do or he could just focus on
the King side which you know it looks
like he wants to do later pushing
forward with e4 trying to control the
center of the board and then attacking
on the King side black responds with
pawn to c5 trying to you know break up
the center of the board and magnus
carlsen decided to take with his pond a
lot of times you'll see you know taking
with a knight here this is pretty common
but magnus carlsen decided to take back
with his pawn definitely one of the
moves in the early of the game that
actually took him quite a while to
figure out what he wanted to do and now
we see pawn to e3 kind of a waiting move
not ready to go ahead and commit with
that pawn to e4 but it does open up for
you know this bishop to get involved
into the action usually pretty common
for this bishop to come to d3 and then
if it wants to get more involved into
the game it can definitely do that once
the bishop comes outside this pawn chain
ix can come to e3 it can then come to f4
a lot of times it comes to g3 and then
the push from efore happens so just a
few things to keep in mind the Starks
square bishop once the pawn pushes
forward to e4 can now get involved into
the action you can also bring your queen
involved to kind of have add some
support Queen here to c2 makes a lot of
sense so just a few things as both
things are looking black still has the
option you can castle on the Queen side
you know he can bring the bishop over
here to f5 is a pretty common square he
can bring his knight here to c6 he can
bring his queen where everyone
ass on the queen's head or you could
just opt for castling on the king's side
decides to go ahead and push forward
with pawn to c4 kind of blocking off any
momentum that white may have with
pushing forward on the Queen side also
stops the Bishop from coming here to d3
which as we've already talked about is
definitely something that a nan would
want to do with the bishop because
that's typically the square that the
bishop is going to come to in the
nimzo-indian defense is the square right
here on d3 now that responds with a
knight here it's e to getting ready to
again come over here to g3 and then we
see Knight to c6 now keep in mind this
is very important from here magnus
carlsen could just decide to go ahead
and castle on the Kings side but if he
kind of looks at it you know you could
see the knight come here to g3 and then
you know you could have the pawn push
forward to h5 and in this particular
case you don't want to have your king
castled over here you want to be able to
attack this so he decides to go ahead
and just play Knight here to c6 because
now if we look at it okay now if the
knight comes to g3 now we can go ahead
and have that pawn to h5 and we're not
too worried about you know that the King
not being safe because black can still
castle on the Queen side so it's kind of
a waiting move to see what exactly why
it's going to do knowing that black is
going to play this Knight to c6 at some
point in the game so nan plays pawn to
g4 which if you were actually watching
the game is pretty exciting pawn to g4
it's kind of an all and move that says
I'm just going to push very very quickly
I'm pretty much all in I have to get a
win here so none of this funny business
of we're going to draw after 20 moves
someone is going to win this game's
definitely kind of exciting again if you
look at it white can castle on either
side but really there's going to be no
safety here it makes more sense to
castle on the Kings side because you do
have kind of the the pawns in front of
it so as you push it's going to be very
tough for black to even counter-attack
because he's going to have to worry
about protecting but again this is a
very very strong indicator that anon is
just going to be pushing and putting a
lot of pressure on
Karlsson if I'm playing this game for
Magnus Carlsen I'm really just trying to
hold on for a draw the last thing you
want to do is have an on get a win here
being down only a point with three games
left and just giving him that confidence
going into the last three games Magnus
Carlsen now decides to go ahead and
castle on the Kings side so it's just
going to be a race if you kind of look
at this you can see that anon has
already started to attack on the King
side Magnus has decided to castle on the
King side and so now it's just time to
March up here and start to attack this
King on GA bruh we now see the bishop
come here to g2 indicating that he wants
to go ahead and castle on the King side
again the bishop usually wants to come
to d3 but because it can't the next
logical Square is right here on g2 now
the night's going to come over here to
a5 getting ready for a nice little
outpost here on a b3 this is definitely
going to be tough for white to deal with
especially since we talked about this
LightSquared bishop over here on g2 it's
not going to be moving it it's kind of
awkward for this night to really get too
involved he wants to be over here on the
King side so he's not going to be able
to do too much over here now after the
castle on the King side we see the
knight come over here to be 3 and then
the rook swings over to a1 easy for nan
to play B 1 or a 2 both are completely
fine b1 makes a lot of sense because it
controls the semi-open file but as long
as this rooks here on b1 this night
could just hang out on b3 pretty much
just locks down a semi-open file so this
rook here on a2 does make some sense it
allows it if it needs to ever swing over
to the King side it can definitely get
involved very very quickly in the action
now the pawns going to push forward on
b5 Magnus Carlsen recognizes ok anons
going to push on the King side what's
the plan if he just sits back and just
takes it on the chin he's going to lose
this match his only way to even fight
for a draw or potentially a win if
there's a blunder later in the game is
to attack on the Queen side he has to
it's the only option that he really has
in this game so nan plays Knight to g3
but again he's already played this g4 so
this is even more
recive he can play night here to f5 if
he wants to he can now push forward with
pawn to e4 put even more pressure on the
kingside magnus carlsen again sticking
with his plan an on pushing on the
kingside black pushing on the queenside
who's going to end up winning in this
particular game and now pawn to g5
putting even more pressure forcing this
knight's move the knight moves back here
to be eight and then we see e4 s we
talked about kind of crushing up the
center of the board here we now see the
knight take here on c1 the exchange
giving up you know as knight for that
dark square bishop usually again don't
want to have your opponent with double
bishop pair especially when your
opponent has such a strong attack over
here
so after this takes we have the rook
swing over here to a6 trying to control
you know stopping some of this attack
that why it's going to be pushing up the
board right here and then we see pawn to
e5 in a non hat a lot of different
options here as far as you could have
played I really think he five is a
fantastic move right here it blocks off
a lot of the options that black has the
knight can't come here to these six it
stops it on many ways from coming here
to f6 it again points all this pawn
structure over here to the King side so
it's a lot easier for nan to get more of
his pieces involved into the action on
the King side and you can just overwhelm
his opponent where it's going to be very
very difficult for Magnus Carlsen right
now he has most of his pieces on the
eighth-ranked it's kind of difficult to
even look at and figure out how Magnus
Carson Carlson is going to hang on or
counter-attack in this game we now see
the knight come to c7 again not too many
squares that he can actually come to the
pawns going to push forward to f4 again
and on is just pushing as much as you
can over here my name is Carlson has to
push over on the Queen side he doesn't
have many other options and after the
take we see both sides take right here
and again this Knight over here on a6
it's kind of awkwardly placed it can't
come to c5 it can't come to d6 so it's
going to have to it's made its journey
all the way over here for me eight now
it's going to have to make the journey
back if it wants to get involved into
the action but we see pawn to f5
I have again pushing forward both sides
are continuing and pawn to b3 so magnus
carlsen is looking to push forward he
now has an unprotected past pawn that
White's gonna have to worry about the
rest of the game because this is
definitely a threat Magnus Carlsen is
doing what he needs to do attacking on
the Queen side now the Queen comes up
here to f4 Anan is completely all in all
of his pieces are over here getting
ready for the attack and now it's just
kind of who strikes first who's going to
be too overwhelmed for the other
opponent to actually do anything so now
we see Knight to c7 again we already
talked about it needs to get back
involved into the action wasn't doing
too much over here on a6 and now the
pawn pushes forward to f6 few ways to
really defend against this in the
particular game we saw pawn to g6 which
has its own challenges in itself but you
know if we look and see pawn takes on f6
then just you know the knight coming to
h5 has so many complications for black
to deal with can be very very tricky so
kind of took the safer route although it
still is very complicated in playing
this pawn here to g6 Queens now I'm
going to come to h4 getting ready to
come to h6 and then to g7 checkmate
black has to deal with this brings his
knight over here to e8 stopping the
attack here on g7 Magnus Carlsen is kind
of in defense mode but he does have this
secret weapon over here on b3 if an on
ever brings his guard down now we see
the Queen come over here to h6 and then
pawn to be to Magnus Carlsen recognizes
okay I've stopped this over here and I'm
going to go ahead and play pawn to b2
and you're going to have to respect this
and anon says I don't respect that at
all I'm going to play rook over here to
f4 getting ready to swing over to h4 and
I'm going to checkmate you on h7 Magnus
Carlsen said okay that's a cool plan I'm
going to go ahead and play Queen here to
b1 and things just get crazy here from
here we have you know this is just
analyzing the situation anon has the
option of playing bishop here to f1 and
then the works going to swing over to
all right guess black plays plays Queen
over here to d1
because after the rook swings over here
to h4 have some something has to stop
the route or the Queen come coming here
to h7 this nights going to not going to
be doing anything so the Queen now comes
up here to h5 now we have the night take
and then after the pawn takes we have
the rook take here but now the bishop
can come here to f5 and things are
actually protected there's now a piece
that's protecting this square here on h7
but things still get pretty complicated
this is going to be very difficult for
both sides to deal with there's so many
sharp variations so again
Magnus Carlsen gets that Queen but he's
forced to give it right back because of
the threats that anon has in a
particular game and again that's kind of
what both sides are looking at
unfortunately in the game there was a
huge blunder an on actually rushed in
this particular case and instead of
playing what he had to have Bishop to f1
he instead played Knight to f1 and when
he didn't realize is that Magnus Carlsen
could play Queen to e1 because his
knight was no longer on g3 this queen is
now defending here on h4 an on really
wants to play this rook over here to h4
so we can play Queen to two h7 but after
this Magnus Carlsen can just give his
queen back he doesn't care too much that
he just exchanged a queen for a rook
because he got that Queen for free down
here on b1 he's got his other queen over
here on the d8 so after this exchange
all of a sudden we look at and we say
okay and Nan doesn't have any more
threats
all of a sudden Magnus Carlsen is a rook
up in material this is going to be a
very easy game for Magnus Carlsen to win
so an on after he played this f1 Magnus
Carlsen kind of stared at the board with
a really weird look on his face as if to
say did you really just play f1 i am i
missing something I don't understand and
then he played immediately or not
immediately was a few minutes after
stared at it weirdly played Queen to e1
and immediately got up and you can
actually hear the Norwegian cheering
section going crazy because everyone
kind of realized that this match had
been won so after the Queen 2e1 anon
decided to go ahead and resign
Magnus Carlsen goes up three points with
three games left in this series meaning
that if for the next three games Magnus
Carlsen can even tie and get half a
point he will be the new world chess
champion which is I think fantastic for
the games such a young bright star as we
can see in these particular games all
out of nowhere can pull rabbit out of
his hat as always aggressive when he
needs to be is extremely good in the in
game all of his games I really enjoyed
watching so again game 9 Magnus Carlsen
wins it goes up three points in this
particular match hopefully you guys
watching this series I'm excited to see
the next three matches just to see if
they go out guns blazing or what it's
going to look like but I think we're
going to have a new world champion in
the very near future I'll see you guys
in the next video thanks for watching